[Music]
I'm gonna rap hip-hop fans in the place
to be make some noise
not everybody make some noise if you're
sympathetic to at least some rap music
but are a little bit suspicious of me
asking you the question I know it's the
hottest pink button front Western shirt
in the rap game you guys we're gonna do
this thing I do have a couple rap songs
to perform for you and here's the first
one
DJ drop that beat it's a flat roast
I'm gonna roast some flags and I don't
want to show up boast or brag but you
know I got the devastating gags and
jokes getting aggro it's a flag roast I
mean I'd murder Flags when I put him on
blast all surviving flags should be at
half-mast show me any flag and that
Flags toast listen close it's a flank
roast I firmly defile banners in a
highly vile manner
hey Isle of Man I demand some answers
why is your logo so bizarre three
disembodied legs fused into a ninja
throwing star don't get me wrong though
your self-esteem should be strong who
came up with the three strap song and of
all the world's flags yours is top of
the list in terms of the amount of
crotch is two picks
here's futon I want to commend them
Congrats guys you really nailed it on
the emblem the symbol of your heritage
and Glory falkor the luckdragon for the
never
story come on I'm just goofin Bhutan
stirs that dragon under flag is the
scariest of monsters although he looks
pretty frail and he fails when you weigh
them on the scales against this badass
from Wales great that's a way tougher
dragon and they got to scrap it imagine
what would happen I'll do some
reenacting Monaco's design was fine but
it was stolen by Indonesian Singapore
and Coleman you all should be a shame
that you came to such a lame decision
that's black plagiarism lord plagiarisms
flies get laced like high-tops you
better brace for the flag bombs i
dropped
here's Mauritania or as I call it the
Jolly Green cyclops and not to make you
blush or turn crimson but the flag of
antigua and barbuda is kind of like
glimpsing the first person he loved
performing oral sex on Lisa Simpson
right you got the hair pink dress the
way look the Simpsons premiered in 1989
she's a grown woman by now this is not
creepy
didn't you talk about Lisa Simpsons
badge groves toughen up wimps it's flat
gross man it's like set feet they get
their toes tagged I put them in body
bags when I gross Flags
you should pity any flag that I sing
this dag sting is agonizing I'm that
dude who will rag on their flag the most
Jack Serling with the flag rose
[Music]
[Applause]